madame mademoiselle messieurs bonjour si
vous nous rejoignez seulement maintenant
sur antenne 2 je vous souhaite à tous et
à toutes une très bonne et très heureuse
nouvelle année il y a bien entendu un
programme de fête un programme tout à
fait exceptionnelle cet après midi sur
antenne 2 puisque nous sommes le 1er
janvier 1981 alors à partir de 14h
sachez que vous pourrez découvrir une
comédie musicale qui vous est proposée
par bruno fourcade et qui a pour titre
une brebis pas comme les autres il
s'agit d'une comédie menée avec beaucoup
de charme beaucoup de malice et
interprété par le petit conservatoire de
mireille à 15h05 notez-bien 15h05 ce
rendez vous quatre grands noms du cinéma
français seront en tête d'affiche pour
vous faire rire et ce dans le cadre de
ciné noël vous avez en effet rendez vous
avec le bossu il s'agit d'un film tourné
en 1959 par andré hunebelle est aspiré
est un roman mélodramatique de paul
féval paru en 1858 je vous donnerai
d'ailleurs plus de détails sur ce film
un petit peu plus tard dans l'après midi
lorsqu'il sera je pense 14h à 16h45
nous nous rendrons au cirque eux pour
voir les prouesses du cirque barnum et à
17h50 jeunes amis oui vous avez rendez
vous avec récré a2 18h ne manquez pas le
16ème épisode dacca guerra aujourd'hui
il s'agira de découvrir une famille bien
tranquille oui en effet une famille de
treize gorille simplement donc un rendez
vous avec les animaux bien entendu avec
l'humour à partir de 18h dans l'immédiat
je vous invite à retrouver un nouveau
numéro de la série fenêtre sur une série
que vous propose chaque jour sylvie
genevoix et aujourd'hui vous allez
découvrir les pèlerins du chant choral
que se passe-t-il chaque année à vaison
la romaine qui sont ces envahisseurs qui
hante tous les lieux publics et qui
chantent
eh bien nous allons tout de suite le
découvrir dans cette émission réalisée
par henry joue à tout à l'heure et bon
d'après midi
et